let's do this [ __ ] [ __ ] in five
four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
are the podcast that's here to talk
about basically anything that you [ __ ]
won and if you have a long commute or
you're just bullshitting all day well
that's what we're here for we're the
genius brain podcast baby we got Joe
[ __ ] Jitsu Kalwa every Thursday
how dull konichiwa
konichiwa you stupid [ __ ] hoi my
asses yeah you know there's an
interesting topic that I feel that a lot
of Asian Americans and you know we
typically I guess you know because we
are Asian American men you know we do
have ideas about these topics that we
don't really kind of focus a lot of our
videos on these things because it kind
of comes off really corny
but yeah I feel like I do want to put my
two cents in on this topic just because
I feel there's a lot of people out there
who aren't us or me you Bart or whatever
that have a very specific opinion about
Asian masculinity yeah
that's the exact opposite of us well
what's being pet perpetrate perpetuated
or pitch I said perpetrated the birther
trade well there's different schools of
thought yeah right and to me it's all
about the narrative people want to treat
it as if there's like we're a monolith
and we think one [ __ ] way and the
Asian male experience is one [ __ ] way
which I highly disagree with and in
academia and maybe like culture studies
or even the guys out there that are kind
of like leading this thought I don't
agree with and I think that if we don't
speak up and if we don't show the world
that we [ __ ] disagree with this
thought yeah what's gonna do is I think
it's gonna poison our culture which is
what it is doing and I think there's a
difference between the objective truth
and how you define it I mean there's a
difference between the objective truth
right facts and someone's opinion and
someone's basic like their own
experience is not the truth experience
of for all [ __ ]
asian-americans yeah but people out
there talking as if it is for example a
lot of people that are that have low
self-esteem they think oh you know it's
hard being an Asian man because I can't
get dates but to me it's not an Asian
problem it's a you problem that's a low
self-esteem problem yeah it has nothing
to do with a woman's perception of your
VAT like of your value because of your
race that just goes to show what you
think how [ __ ] dumb women are you
think women are that [ __ ] dumb that
they'll choose like a race for it for
that's it yeah like that and if all
women are that [ __ ] dumb that they'll
choose a mate based off of race and they
think that you're you're pretty or hot
or whatever based off of your race then
that means you think most women out
there are [ __ ] idiots yeah and that's
not to say that those type of people
don't exist because we know those type
of people who have a certain type look I
know like white chicks that only date
black dudes I know Asian people that
only date Asian girls so it's like you
know we could kind of use that same
excuse right back at you right they're
like whoa if you're saying that certain
women only don't find Asian men
attractive because there's a stereotype
that Asian dudes are [ __ ] ugly that
might just because you're actually
[ __ ] ugly
you know I mean exactly that's just true
but then people make this argument right
they'll be like well this is because the
white man controls everything and
there's a Western standard of beauty and
because there's a Western standard of
beauty like whatever whatever right but
then all these [ __ ] that have been
saying this in the 90s and early 2000s
right it's been the same weak low
self-esteem argument because I heard
this [ __ ] and I didn't believe it and I
was like y'all just in cells before
there was even a word called in cell I
was thinking y'all are cock-blocking
yourself with that stupid mentality
right but they'll also turn around and
be like well you know this is
Hollywood's doing because there's no
[ __ ] you know Asian roles that are
sexy so we don't looked upon as sexy and
I'm like bro it's not the white man's
job to get us late yeah so [ __ ] that you
know it's yours
to put your best foot forward and get
out there and [ __ ] socialize and
[ __ ] have fun and connect with people
and have romantic relationships also I'm
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] is
with your obsession with trying to get
white women to like you and why do they
put them on in up on a pedestal yeah I
don't understand I don't get that [ __ ]
either like what is this thing that it's
like Oh white women don't like why do
you want them to like you so bad what
what is the Constitution to the value of
an Asian insel there so race obsessed
right that I think they put white women
at the highest of the totem pole
although every slice it's like us like
what a [ __ ] badge it's like I got a
white girl there's a asian guy is that
what that [ __ ] is I think it's like this
if there if the way that they see the
world is different races have different
value and they see themselves as the
Asian man has the lowest value then
obviously what they're looking at is
women the same way they're looking at
women white women maybe at the top value
and like I don't know whatever levels
that they believe yeah so if they see
themselves as low value on the totem
pole then they're looking at women the
same way and it's very odd too because
they go like these hot white girls they
would never date an Asian guy it's like
yeah they wouldn't date you and it's not
even the white girl part it's the hot
girl wouldn't date you whether they're
white black Mexican it doesn't [ __ ]
matter yeah the hot girl wouldn't
[ __ ] date exactly your person now
they said also you're probably [ __ ]
hideous and this is coming from a guy
who's not that attractive himself either
you're probably not that good-looking
dude I ran into a [ __ ] like this
during my Europe trip yeah I ran into a
[ __ ] Asian American we were all
hanging out right and um there were
there were there were European girls
there that spoke English we're all just
hanging out and the cool thing about
Europe is like they're really into
culture they can have intellectual
conversations a lot of them are very
educated and worldly so we'll have these
talks about the difference in culture
and this [ __ ] he comes out saying I
don't like white girls in America
because he was I don't like white girls
in America they don't give me the time
of day but I want a girlfriend in Europe
because European girls
they all they all like me and I was like
they all like you go or like basically
he's he didn't say that exactly but he
was just saying how like European girls
give him a chance and then he goes off
to saying some stupid [ __ ] about like I
want a powerful passport like if I date
a European girl I don't want like a [ __ ]
Eastern European country like I want
like a top western country and the girls
started looking at him like who is this
[ __ ] [ __ ] right he's a boy he's saying
this in front of women exactly he's [ __ ]
blocking himself and I'm looking at him
and I'm all like no that's not true like
a [ __ ] dude right and I'm like white
women they talk to you people just as
black women talk to people like what are
you saying like yes racism does exist
I'm not even gonna deny the fact that it
doesn't exist but I'm saying like most
people are friendly normal [ __ ]
people because it's just an easy way out
it's an easy excuse for you to say
because of my ethnicity that's the
reason why these things are happening
yeah me now I get it
on it like a systemic level of racism
and all this other [ __ ] but we're just
talking about the traction in general
right yeah and humans like here's the
thing man like in and I was sitting
there with some other like British
Vietnamese dudes and and they were
looking at me and they're like yo
people's is people's bro that's people
those peoples right and then I'm like
does this happen in the UK or Europe and
he's like nah like look around you like
everybody's with everybody and he's
right
I saw Indian dudes with like Russian
girls and I saw like Asian guys with
like Spanish girls or whatever and you
know vice versa
there's just everyone's dating each
other right and he's like why is America
so race obsessed and Asian men there
don't have this feeling or low
self-esteem or maybe it was the guys I
was around because the guys I were
around they were straight playas like
they were they were not afraid of women
like we would go to the club or we would
go have hookah or whatever or shisha and
they they they don't have any shame and
just saying hi what's your name like
let's have a conversation
that one boy the asian-american dude he
was to me he was quite a bit of an in
cell like he's he he kind of gets weird
around women like I can tell if he's
having that conversation in front of a
[ __ ] date you [ __ ] [ __ ] what are
you doing dude right like what the [ __ ]
are you doing like are you that socially
[ __ ] stupid like you're on a date and
the right girls
so there's white women why the [ __ ]
would you have a conversation about how
much you hate white women right it's
stupid um no but they I think this is
the thing man everyone that has that
mentality of oh it's tough for our Asian
guys cuz we can't do this or whatever
right to me they don't realize the low
self-esteem that they have and then in
the lack of social skills because
everyone knows that it's not these
criterias that get you like a
relationship or whatever it's the energy
and connection that you have with the
human being if you understand social
skills if you understand the ability to
let someone feel comfortable wanted
accepted loved the things that make you
a human being not [ __ ] categories
that's like duffle you don't get it but
we do have a pretty you know I don't
want to say big but I a vocal group of
Asian Americans that feel as though that
this is the truth and I want to break
that [ __ ] because it's not the truth but
they'll have these excuses they'll be
like oh it's because you have a
following and I'm like [ __ ]
before I had a following I was talking
to all kinds of girls yeah I didn't see
it as like asian girls are the only ones
that'll date me yeah I was like I grew
up around a lot of Latina and Asian but
some of my best memories were you know
with like black and Latino girls like I
mean it's not even like I'm a [ __ ]
playa is just me she's pretty she's
attracted to meet your shot that's what
happens let's go to the movies let's
have some you know like what the [ __ ]
and I was broke [ __ ] skinny as [ __ ]
had a [ __ ] car none of those things
mattered it's all about making a goddamn
connection and for me I'm pulling my
hair because these fools are so [ __ ]
stupid like they don't think that it's
that easy well and also to what's
problematic
that type of conversation especially if
you're if you're like an Asian whatever
influencer right is that you are under
the guise of saying that number one I am
for my culture I want people to think
that we're dope but the rhetoric the
language that you have doesn't speak for
that [ __ ] yeah you are saying that the
crutch in your life is because you're
Asian but you want to be recognized as
an Asian leader shut the [ __ ] up
yeah it's not leadership that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] to me I've always been very [ __ ]
proud yeah because I don't see the same
[ __ ] and negative things that they do
yeah where they see Oh Asians don't get
[ __ ] roles on film I see good less
[ __ ] competition
[ __ ] when they see ya oh they
think Asians are a bunch of nerd I'm
like good they're intimidated of our
[ __ ] intelligence yeah let's use that
against them I'm a [ __ ] leader like
those guys they're out here complaining
like a little [ __ ] and to me that makes
us look worse yeah if you're a prominent
Asian figure and you're out there going
like oh well you know the stereotype is
this day and I'm out here to break that
[ __ ] you sound like a little [ __ ] that
wants respect
yeah just [ __ ] go out there and take
it god damn it
it's so it's so weird to hear that type
of language to for a lot of people
because they they sometimes they go well
it's because you grew up this way you
grew up that you know what you're damn
straight like I did grow up around a lot
of strong Asian men so even to counter
your argument they exist out there they
exist but I think that the Asians that
are doing hard [ __ ] aren't [ __ ]
talking and complaining they're not the
most vocal [ __ ] are the ones that are
the weakest because they're the first
ones to start bitching but don't get me
wrong like we do need to speak up we do
need to address problems we do need to
fight for our rights all those things I
agree with it's the way we go by it yeah
right so like I just saw this little
next-next shark thing
BAM baller was coming basically he was
talking about how a lot of Asians are
soft yeah and we needed like toughen up
and I do agree it's just that there's a
vocal group within our community
that they represent the voice in their
way of doing things is that it sounds
like bitching it doesn't sound powerful
it doesn't sound confident
it sounds like an insecure bunch of
[ __ ] that are like please stop
treating us this way
this podcast is brought to you by post
mates oh my goodness gracious what can I
say about post mates that I I just I
just haven't said before post mates is
the best it's like my best friend that
will do anything and everything for me
any time of the night because sometimes
I don't know at like 11:00 p.m. I wants
me a bottle of wine from a beverage
place but I'm too lazy to go out and get
it myself
well that's why I swim whip open my post
mates app and he gets it for me you have
no idea how many times I drank myself
into an oblivion and I couldn't wake up
to get myself a good bowl of pho well
guess what I didn't have to because I
didn't hit a post mades baby yes I love
post mate all you got to do is download
the app for iOS or Android for free and
they just bro how's the local
restaurants and businesses and you track
your delivery in real time you could see
like on this map where you see the
person just come up to you with the food
she's gotta let them know how you want
to receive it and there you go bing bang
boom you got delivery to any of your
restaurants or a majority of them that
you like straight to your freaking door
I love post mates for a limited time
post mates is giving our listeners $100
of free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use code brain
that's code brain for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need anytime you need it
post mated download post mates and save
with code brain yeah you know what's
interesting too about that I think one
of the strengths that I thought well III
think it's once again its language in
perspective that I thought was really
great about Asian people was the fact
that we didn't have to say [ __ ] we would
do [ __ ] I love that you know I made yeah
so we didn't have to go on Twitter talk
all this [ __ ] they go Asian people are
dope it's like of course we're dough we
own all half the business in this
[ __ ] neighborhood
we're making [ __ ] money our kids are
going to Ivy League colleges we are
taking up a majority of the the roster
in your academic school you C's have
over 40% Asian populations yeah so it's
like we don't have to say it we do it
that's what we're about that's what
we've always been about so that's what I
was taught right my heart
um what she told me is during world war
ii you know japanese people were rounded
up taken to the camps whatever and there
was rumors or just the word spread out
in the camps the reason why they threw
us in caps was you know they thought we
were foreigners they didn't throw in the
the German Americans the Italians or
whatever because they thought they were
full-blooded Americans this is what we
need to do as a community we need to go
in we need to send our kids to the
military we need to have them take high
positions in government in military and
community we need to speak English
proficiently we need to go in there and
become a part of the culture to the
point where they could never do this to
our people ever again yeah it wasn't
let's go and [ __ ] hit those bongo
drums outside in March it's like nah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you know
so the first Asian American one of the
generals was a japanese-american first
senator politician what would you call
it congressmen they're all
japanese-americans because that [ __ ]
fight to go in and being like all right
we're gonna be a force to be reckoned
with so within our community what I was
always taught is every time you got a
fight for some [ __ ] take it the [ __ ]
over where it's effective and I get it
there is a time and place to protest and
use your voice if it wasn't for that we
would have never got the apology from
the u.s. to the japanese-american
community we we have to battle it out in
court but to me that's still having a
voice where it's effective you go to
court you do the [ __ ] debates right
you go and you speak in you rally people
up for something that's effective and it
makes sense if you're out there and
you're bitching about Asian guys have it
hard
getting having a hard time getting laid
because we're not in movies
that's a stupid [ __ ] reason to be
fighting for something you know and this
is what I kind of appreciate about black
culture too I mean I mean there's people
who have different differing opinions
about this but when it's it's almost as
if some of these guys who talk about you
know getting the white woman right yeah
like you'll hear a lot of Asian dudes
they go they see an Asian dude with the
white girl they go yeah [ __ ] that guy
got one right yeah but conversely like
in the black culture when you see a
black day with a beautiful black woman
they celebrate that woman they go you
found a beautiful black woman to be with
yeah for some reason like within our
culture I don't feel like there's this
thing where you see a Asian do with the
beautiful Asian woman you go that's
amazing like I'm glad that you found
somebody within your course beautiful
but first like they celebrate the the
fact that you got somebody outside of
the race which is cool too that's fine I
mean we live in America where we're a
melting pot of cultures what we're
supposed to be but for some reason it's
not celebrated in our in our culture in
our asian-american culture it's weird
yeah and I know I heard from some guys
when they see like a Asian girl with a
white guy or a Mexican guy they they see
her as a race traitor oh really
yeah well there are okay weird there are
weird people just guys innate like just
both male and female Asians that they
have some type of weird identity thing
where they almost are racist like
there's that sale self-hate there is a
there's a group right because I mean
they it sucks man there's like a
compilation of cuts of women saying [ __ ]
Asian women like oh I don't I'm not
really that attracted to Asian guys even
though I'm Asian it's they're pretty
ugly or like they say some really
fucked-up [ __ ] and for me that I don't
that that that that self-hate [ __ ] is
weird too it's just as weird as people
you know that are hella in cell and only
want like top-notch Latin girls or white
girls or whatever right the way that
they're approaching it there's a level
of this I'm ashamed that I'm even Asian
because Asian people embarrass me yeah
and I know there's a sector of people
like that I'm not even gonna deny that
they exist but here's the thing though
like when people are just generally in
love and you see a white coming an agent
girl with a white guy or whatever there
there is a there's there are Asian guy
that look at it they're like oh they're
taking all our women you know and I see
[ __ ] weird I think it's important to
note too that I think when we say these
things we're not saying that those
people who've had these like anecdotal
or very specific experiences where they
felt this type of like I guess inter
inter racism that it hasn't happened or
it doesn't exist but the problem is that
I see is that you're taking personal
experiences or sometimes I don't even
want to say sometimes a lot of these
people that I've heard this from that
had this argument dude you can't even
get any girl to date you yeah
so where is your opinion about this
specific race who you want that they
don't like you it's like it's not just
the white girl it's the black girls the
basic girls the Asian girl they all
don't like yeah yeah what the [ __ ]
basically doesn't [ __ ] like you yeah
even I even probably like [ __ ] is like
actual female docs by one you'll [ __ ]
walk up to you you dumb [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] and when people put like one race
or one type on a pedestal right do they
even think hey maybe you have so much
confidence with Asian girls because
you're so used to that
and anytime you're speaking to a latin
girl black or white or whatever it is
you're so scared and you're so not
yourself
that you act differently which invokes a
different type of reaction in them yeah
and they never see it that way because
they're socially [ __ ] stupid yeah
like maybe you're comfortable in your
comfort zone and so you could be
yourself a little more and then when you
see somebody outside of what you
normally approach you don't know how to
act like you act weird like how many
times have you seen this [ __ ] where were
you seen a dude that clearly didn't grow
up around a single black person or
whatever and the moment you see somebody
with a little melanin in their skin
they're just like hey what's up fam
what's poppin was good it's like bro
what the [ __ ] I've seen that so many
time it's like where the [ __ ] did this
come from you suburb [ __ ] likes it as
if they're Asian it's so [ __ ]
embarrassing yeah cuz I'm like why the
[ __ ] dude you grew up in a [ __ ]
suburb full of white people and like
where did you pick this up yeah like
just chill relax man it's not why do you
extra urbanize yourself around black
people the [ __ ]
I see it so often - and it cracks me up
and you know I think everybody does that
like shape-shifting thing a little bit
right because we want people to be
comfortable around their
whatever-whatever they're comfortable
when we have conversation right yeah we
all do that a little bit like when a cop
pulls me over you're damn straight I'm
like hello officer like I definitely do
that [ __ ] - when I have meetings with
with white people I definitely speak a
little different yeah of course because
we're humans and we want a mirror yeah
but the excessive level of that is just
[ __ ] weird it's hysterical man pretty
weird like yo I know this one home girl
- like she every time I [ __ ] [ __ ] you
not you see anybody with like a drop of
black in them she just come down she
goes okay what's up let's pop it was
good it's like [ __ ] shut up and you
know we had this conference I like we're
drinking I got a little drunk and I kind
of call her out on that [ __ ] I was like
yo how come every time you see one
[ __ ] black person like all of a sudden
you over you're like doing that bone
quiqui like [ __ ] she doesn't even know
she does not you know what the funny
[ __ ] is she the first thing she said was
she's like you're not the only person
that grew up around black people eyes
like I know but you did it you know
exactly I know who you're talking about
I know I know facts like you did it so
it's like I'm not like the black
ambassador or whatever whatnot but it's
just a so really odd thing cuz you could
tell - when she does that though they
feel a little uncomfortable - and it's
inauthentic yeah and they're try not
reading the room exactly and sometimes -
I see them like they're trying to
entertain her a little bit like yeah oh
she's trying to be a part of the culture
so why the [ __ ] not which is really dope
of them but for me when I see that
sometimes it's like you didn't have to
do that you're a great person yeah
you're just dope in general you're a
talented [ __ ] energetic human being
if you would have just been yourself you
don't think that these people would have
just accepted you for what you were yeah
like that's that's all good you don't
have to do that [ __ ] and like I trust me
like I said I understand like when I
like Mariel sees it sometimes too like
she always so it's funny because the the
last place that she lived in the the
front what do you call it the security
people at her apartment complex they're
all black right and a majority that I'm
sorry a majority them are black but
every now and then there's like there's
like I forgot her name I think her name
was Shelley but she was like a white
lady that would be there she Mariel
looks at me doctor we would go in a few
times she goes it's she goes you know
what's really funny about you I'm like
what's funny
she goes when you speak to the white
lady Shelly you're very like you seems
like you're almost a little cold but the
moment you see like a like a black woman
they're like you guys talk you chop it
up like you're super comfortable around
them and I was like well it's because
that's what I grew up around like I know
how we joke about the same things we
laugh about the same thing so you feel
like I feel like surely it makes sense
you're comfortable exactly so it's like
it's you know and then you're walking on
eggshells maybe because you didn't
you're not too used to the Whitely yeah
cuz I don't know I'm not comfortable I
don't know if you might offend her or
you might be unprofessional or just the
boundaries are weird for sure yes I
stuff that's built in my head it's just
not something that I'm used to all the
time like I've gotten better now now I
just I'm just myself a hundred percent
all the time but for sure like if I'm
around like black Asian Mexican it's
easier for me because that's what I've
seen growing up my whole life yeah so if
we if we Sparkle calm spark up a
conversation and we chop it up it's just
gonna be naturally easy from yeah right
like we could I know how to joke around
with like black folk NGO Mexican folk
yeah because that's just we share the
same sense of humor
so even when Mario saw it she thought I
think like she kind of thinks that
sometimes I'm marrying the culture yeah
which I understand - I can get it which
in it to a certain level of to a certain
extent I am but it's something that I
grew up with my whole life it's a level
of comfort yeah because people that are
international that are listening to this
they really don't get how segregated the
u.s. is sure we are a race upset
obsessed group of people you know you
mentioned that and I do agree we are
very very race obsessed here and very
category like wheat like oh no I'm Asian
American and you know what's funny is I
was talking to a Canadian friend of mine
and she was saying like you know in
Canada we don't do that
Asian Canadian yeah white Canadian
whatever Canadian there's a because I
blow youtubers that make videos about
[ __ ] yeah we're just we're just we're
just Canadians [ __ ] Canadians and
then it's like or you're from Montreal
or Quebec
you know your equipment your your your
Frenchie whatever yeah and I'm like oh
that that makes sense
and yeah there's brown people white
people whatever but they're not so damn
race obsessed they're just people
people are very label obsessed though
like they got but for some reason for a
society that I
always read up all the time they go
don't label me don't tell me what to be
but the moment somebody quote-unquote
miss labels them they're like what
that's the wrong label it's like we you
can't have it both ways yeah like labels
or do you not do you want to just exist
and be yourself or do you want to label
to tie you to what you really are yeah
because are you is your personality a
category or would you rather define who
you are independently yeah I always go
for independent right and in people or
students always ask me when I go speak
at colleges and stuff and they go do you
feel responsible for representing Asian
Americans and I say you should never
first look at me as a role model or
anyone that should be speaking for Asian
Americans as a whole like as a president
like I'll say my thoughts but they are
my individual thoughts I have my own
experiences but at the same time I can't
stand by and watch while other Asians
are pushing this [ __ ] [ __ ] narrative
that I do not agree with about our
people about the men in our society
about our value to other people all that
[ __ ] like they're talking about it as if
it's the [ __ ] truth and I'm like [ __ ]
no it's not yeah that's not my
upbringing and that's not what I believe
in and I also want to go out there and
start talking about this stuff because I
actually want to help people that think
this way yeah if you are an Asian dude
with low self-esteem and you don't get
it yet and you're using all this
knowledge all this research all this
[ __ ] whatever you think are facts to
to argue for the point why you don't get
laid
why you don't why you're not successful
why you can't get the job why there's a
bamboo ceiling all these things now I'm
not denying that these things exist in
society
I'm just saying it's not probably
affecting you as much as you think it
does and you have every [ __ ] power in
your own personality and your in your
own lives and your own [ __ ] if you
put your word if you put work towards
doing this of overcoming that and not
being an expected stereotype that you
think you are yeah and we can change the
bar because it's a perception thing
because when we [ __ ] started the
percent
about Asian guys or Asians in general
was they didn't have much they thought
we were foreigners they thought we were
you know people that were nerds or maybe
exchange students or we didn't have a
good brand in entertainment right and
then we start to change [ __ ] Wong foo
started to change stuff dancers Asian
dancers winning all of those American
america's best dance crews they change
the perception the fitness world you
have bar you know introducing asians to
powerlifting which is crazy you know
what i didn't even realize how big Bart
was in terms of being a catalyst for
Asian people who wanted the power live
yeah he Co Hanley brought Asian
Americans to powerlifting I had no idea
he's like a godfather in that aspect I
mean there's a lot of other people but
every time somebody mentions like a
power lifting and baton mentioned Bart
yeah like Bart was the guys like you
know you know 80 people can be buff
right right and no one you know and and
that was something that Bart had a break
because when he was a lot younger he
went and saw above Asian dudes cuz you
know when you go to back then was called
Bally's Total Fitness like there were a
lot of ex-con Asian guys that are [ __ ]
ripped right so when he saw that and a
lot of Asian guys had this mentality as
if Asian man can't get game muscle that
was a stupid universal truth back in the
90s and early 2000s I used to believe
that when I was younger too yeah they
they somehow thought I mean dude we're
all human we all have muscle we all can
[ __ ] build muscle right you know
there's they're obviously like I think
I've got red and I think immense fitness
but they were talking about how people
who are you know like black the Senate
they do have like a genetic advantage or
whatever but it's still there I mean
that was impossible impossible they just
mean they got an edge on it that's all
they just have a slight edge as well so
the thing is it's all about believing in
it first and foremost right but if if
the majority of the population believe
this fact or this [ __ ] statistic or
whatever nerd [ __ ] they came out with of
Asian guys being undesirable I would
break the [ __ ] out of that research
because first off how what's their
sample size who they [ __ ] asking
where do they get this information I
just want to see it published I just
want to see a tenderfoot photo of the
guy I just need to see a photo yeah yeah
but let me see what you look people will
quote studies and they were quote
statistics and all that and I could
break every [ __ ] one of those things
down because what it does is it damages
the self-esteem of our people and they
believe this [ __ ] and you have prominent
figures in our community or people with
the voice within our community whether
in academia whatever pushing this [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're lying
this podcast is brought to you by purple
do you have back pain do you sleep like
crap I guarantee you do because you do
not own a purple mattress my friends I
have slept so well since only my purple
mattress and in fact I used to be a
chroma gene I used to be a really surly
surly angry individual well ever since I
owned a purple mattress my life has
changed because better sleep equals
better performance equals better
everything in life that's a David so
guarantee and what I'm saying right now
is that my purple mattress has given me
the best sleep of my life thus I'm
better for it and did you know that
they're just like rocket science
technology behind the material that is
made from this mattress that's built for
you to sleep really well we're talking
about rocket science stiffs developed at
my friend's yes I'm not be asking you
densest facts so check it out um the
pro-bowl mattress will feel very unique
to you but guess what 100 night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns
you're going to love purple and right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering side Y just takes
brain to eight four eight eight eight
the only way to get this free pillow is
to Tex brain two eight four eight eight
eight that's B Rai n two eight four
eight eight eight yeah yo let me say
this too real quick the man who I was
going to vote for Andrew yang Andrew
yang bite by the way I [ __ ] love the
guy I like what he stands for I think
like he's thinking about the future he's
very progressive in that stuff in that
sense and I love the fact that he really
puts the idea of the thousand dollars
think even though I joke about it the
reason why I like it is because it puts
your
puts your destiny in your own hands he
goes here's $1,000 everybody above the
age of 18 in your household will get
$1,000 after you're 18 Yeah right so
though if you choose to have health care
or you choose to have things here's the
ability to do it now it's really up to
you yeah I enjoy that a lot
right it seems a lot more plausible now
having said that all this positive stuff
he is ugly as [ __ ] you think so
I think he's a really good I wouldn't
say ugly he's just a typical goofy
looking Asian dude did you see how
beautiful his wife is no his wife is a
beautiful Asian woman Oh beautiful like
I'm like and so what you say about
Andrew yang then son he's not the
typical Daniel deke I'm saying he's an
alpha [ __ ] he was trying to be
President he doesn't give a [ __ ] that's
what I'm same confidence he is the man
that I'm talking about like it's not
typically what I would you say I'm
joking about the ugly-ass [ __ ]
he's not as attractive so you think he's
out of his his wife is out of his way I
think when people see them yeah right
they might think that she's a little out
of his league in terms of like physical
looks right but yeah that's coming from
somebody like me anyways but the point
what I'm saying is that look at his wife
yeah she's beautiful and on top of that
- she's a boss ass [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
and she decided to meet somebody who met
her standards of being a [ __ ] boss
right so what do you say about that
a man who arguably who in my mind could
be like the next president the United
States not in this term but next her you
know and that's what I want to do is I
really want to inject that confidence
into our people that might be feeling
bitter they might be feeling lost they
might be feeling like hey why try
because they don't like Asian people
anyway or they're not gonna give us a
chance anyway or whatever right that
mentality is is a [ __ ] like seriously
you're a little [ __ ] and you don't
deserve to succeed because you are
sitting there and you're guaranteeing
your futures failure by sitting there
and saying well you know what's the
point like I'm not gonna get a
girlfriend because you know I live in
this town and they're racist or whatever
well move [ __ ] how about that right how
about you [ __ ] move you [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
there's also this weird thing too where
people in the United States were I I
don't understand where this happened but
people believe that where they are born
where they grew up that they
they are guaranteed a job there or
they're guaranteed certain success more
than boy no you're not you're not
guaranteed [ __ ] yeah like I hear this a
lot with people who look for jobs and
careers right yeah the jobs are so
scarce out there it's like well yeah
you're still staying in the same city
you get out yeah if if you really want
to insist like no what you're trying to
say is that I want to make a living
where I'm comfortable in where I grew up
in that's what and that's okay to say
that yeah but to say that there's
absolutely zero jobs for you out there
makes no sense to me because it's hard
to say that because you haven't really
looked as cletus says it's a free
country you all you know you have that
ability like if you're if just to speak
to like a lot of Asian dudes out there
that probably grew up in a very white
area where yeah probably you're not the
standard version of what an attractive
male is there right you do know that you
had this ability to move elsewhere yeah
and at the end of the day women are so
accepting when it comes to looks when it
comes to all of that if you can if you
have charisma if you have the ability to
make people feel connected to you it's
hard for you to believe I know but if
you have it you will be able to find
love and it's like what kind of women
are you going for yeah are you going for
superficial bimbos that like only go for
a guy's looks that is the minority
people like that is not the majority of
women so like all the guys that are
saying this I can clearly tell they have
no experience with girls they're just
making up [ __ ] rules
you know they're making up assumptions
and all this stuff and so I'm just here
like okay there is a school of thought
here within our people that I completely
[ __ ] to test I hate that [ __ ] but how
do I sit here and instead of making them
feel like attacked which I probably been
doing all my life because I hate this
thought how do I help them come into our
world because our world is much more fun
our world is full of enjoyment love
friendship socializing going out
exploring the world and you know and I
think the biggest thing is
accountability exactly I
I think a lot of people are scared of
accountability but accountability is
freedom you know why it count a bit
accountability is freedom it's because
it allows you to understand the world
around you yeah likes it what it does it
says
I can can change this thing that's
[ __ ] up that's what I like about
accountability is like oh I I am
accountable for a lot of these things
that are happening around me but I have
an ability to change it yeah you push
your problems on to other people and
everything else like your race and your
culture you're basically saying I can't
do anything about it what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna sit around I'm going to
complain and I'm gonna make sure that
everybody understand that it's never my
fault yeah it's because I grew up ajun
it's because I grew up in this town and
this but you don't want to change you
don't have an ability to change it
that's why I like accountability because
it shows that you could pinpoint what
the problem is you could take it and
tear it down exactly and that's because
we're leaders right to me that person
who's talking you know he's getting
stepped on he feels like he has no
options he's also created mental
barriers and limitations throughout his
life I don't know what happened like you
know there are people like for example
you know there's some public figures and
the YouTube community you know that even
though they've gotten some level of
success they have a chip on their
shoulder and then they believe this
stuff because maybe they got bullied
maybe they it's all anecdotal obviously
right like they went through a bad
experience so from that point on to me I
call this low level thinking because if
you don't want racism to be perpetuated
right if you don't want these things to
exist you have to think above the people
that you feel are your enemies so if
you're sitting there and you're like why
people bullied me why people races white
people this right you're doing the same
exact thing as those racists by
persecuting a whole entire group of
people you know you got a you got to
come up above that and go no I'm not
gonna let this [ __ ]
determine how everyone else is of this
culture there's great freaking people
out there it's just I had a bad
experience maybe with a handful of
[ __ ] but
I like to believe that the majority of
people are [ __ ] dope and they don't
want this and so when you do the same
[ __ ] to the to the people that are doing
whatever [ __ ] to you you're not rising
above it and to me that is a victim
you're not a leader a leader will rise
above it a leader will say hey guess
what this [ __ ] Rob from me but
I'm not gonna go around and be like hey
now his whole [ __ ] race is a bunch of
shysters and a [ __ ] bunch of you know
burglars and their good-for-nothing
people you go I had a bad experience but
guess what I know there's twenty thirty
forty other people or whatever that
meant that'll make up for this one
[ __ ] cuz I want to see conversely the
people who are so vocal about being
defeated because you're an Asian
American male and these things aren't
happening for you
conversely I want to see the confident
well-dressed well put together handsome
tall asian guy that does that and says
you know what still not a single girl
will talk to me and I guarantee you that
person doesn't exist if he does if he
has low confidence I'm saying he has
good coffee oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
want to see that hat know it I have it
cuz I know those guys I even know guys
that don't [ __ ] look good Doug I got
a personal friend right now right this
dude is I think from an exterior he
looks like this like sex fiend like he's
mr. sexy man but he's a really really
shy [ __ ] guy right a good-looking
dude very talented it's so [ __ ] funny
it's like if women if it's just let's
say if it's just the confidence thing to
and women just women in general don't
find agent men attractive yeah dude I've
seen so much [ __ ] thrown at this guy
just because he looks like mysterious
and it's not that he's mysterious he's
just shy yeah so funny you know and he's
not he's not confident in like the women
stuff I'm serious like he would text me
right he goes hey man like I'm on this
like dating app this girl sent me this
[ __ ] like I don't know how to respond I
was like what do you mean
so she'll send some [ __ ] like this he'll
be like hey what's up level of blush
right right back looks at his [ __ ] you
know likes the way he looks she goes hey
I'm just like down to [ __ ] like so what
you doing tonight right wow you this
fool just roll
that's cool like what the [ __ ] that is
just cool because that's cool I might
you want it I was like you don't know I
was like wait so what did you say he
goes I don't know I don't know what to
say I just wrote that's cool I'm like
reek doubt he freaked out and I'm like
you sexy son of a [ __ ] yeah like I have
never if there has never been a point in
my life where a woman just looked at me
and said I'm down to [ __ ] ya I had to
giggle my way into that [ __ ] yeah so
[ __ ] hard but you used some type of
skill oh for sure I know what I lack and
I know what I'm good at
right I have a mouthpiece I can talk
right so it takes a little longer the
routes a little more difficult to go to
Mordor but I'm gonna get there
eventually if that's what I'm looking
for
do you know there's a there there is a
section of our people a [ __ ] [ __ ]
group of people that they'll go up and
talk to girls right and if they get
denied they go oh what's up you don't
like Asian guys of course I've heard
this a couple times it's like it's not
don't blame it on our culture why'd you
buy women find you we it makes you look
small it makes you look weak dude don't
[ __ ] say stupid [ __ ] like that I
think that's a lot of it is just ugly
personality ugly confidence and just
that's a part of the game bro like
you're supposed to get denied like
you'll get denied by many many many
women just cold approaches before you
find the one that gives you a chance
dude that that's the thing you got to
shoot your [ __ ] shot yeah when you
shoot your shot - guess what women have
this ability to say no to you it's their
choice you [ __ ] rapist you [ __ ]
that's another any self thing to do is
like they feel entitled to the women
yeah like who says man it's it's just so
twisted dude so every time I hear this
thought right
I feel crazy because like I'll challenge
it but there's so many people that agree
with it I'm like so that's your [ __ ]
universal truth like that's it like you
guys you agree on the fact
that we're low value we're not wanted I
hate you know we're not looked upon as
this and that and then and then there's
no solution it's a circle [ __ ] jerk
of complaining and to me I'm like if you
think you're getting stepped on to me
you deserve to be stepped on yeah
because me I refuse to be [ __ ]
stepped on no matter what I do I refused
even if I am getting stepped on I still
refuse to be there and I want to rise up
from it and for me it's like okay if you
want a woman to like you in general if
you don't have the strength in the power
to rise up and and and get what you want
that that's a that's such an
unattractive trait to not have that
confidence that you're gonna fight for
it yeah and I was reading a comment on
the select certain video where this kid
was like he goes yeah I kind of relate
to like Asian men not being attractive
or wanted like well I used to be like 5
feet tall and when I was like 300 pounds
I couldn't get a single girl in life but
but then I lost weight and then I had a
growth spurt and now they like me that's
like what's that gotta do with you being
Asian [ __ ] you were five feet tall 300
pounds you want the verge of death what
the [ __ ] I don't know in any race where
that would get the girls flocking to
them I'm saying look I'm not saying fat
people aren't attract that I was a big
guy when I when I got married oh who by
the way to me Muriel is [ __ ]
beautiful and it's like when I married I
got together I was huge I was a big [ __ ]
she got you at your worst yeah I worry
up uphill from there and I've had a
conversation where I talked to I was
like what was your ideal guy she goes
well a guy that's very active loves rock
climbing mountain climbing he's fit and
I'm like damn I don't fit any of those
categories and that's what I'm saying is
women are so much more forgiving than
went man when it comes to looks like she
probably had this huge goal in criteria
of the type of k-pop star she wanted
[ __ ] swoon her man you just came up
and I can connected I we connected and I
broke that mold like I and I never
thought of my weight being a crutch that
was the biggest thing it wasn't a crutch
yeah you know it was just oh I'm I'm big
cute is what I thought yeah I always
you'll that do yeah like I forget that
you were fat yeah I was watching an old
JK news and I just I couldn't I was like
who the [ __ ] am I looking at right now I
think was I really that [ __ ] big like
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude I saw when all three
of us blew up though we were are like a
toad it looked like a fat Amster man it
was so funny
there was a point you guys maybe may not
have noticed this just because you guys
watched us so often but there was a
point where all of us were all
collectively at the fattest point of our
lives but I was like seventy Joe was
getting really big because this fool
shot him both but he forgot to work out
and then Bart was just going for a
powerlifting strike he looked like a fat
toad it was so funny he was like he said
he was like 230 pounds he was pretty big
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah I was the
biggest I ever was
that [ __ ] was so fun though cuz we would
eat hella lot though yeah you eat so
much I was like 170 180 in and I'm only
five six so yeah I mean I mean just to
kind of wrap this up like I I do
understand if you guys live in a certain
area and that's just how you were
treated but just to go in there and say
that this is how it is for all of us as
Asian men because I can be the
counter-argument to you right like what
I grew up the my sister who's here to uh
who you can't validate my experience and
not just mine a whole [ __ ] ton of Asian
men's experiences yeah outside of also
just this country like Joe was talking
about when he was in Europe his
experiences with those men out there and
how they're just just Navin any type of
girl that they want
I saw straight asian dweebs with like
hot model girls yeah and I was like this
is the most oddest couple I've ever seen
but it's really okay at the end of the
day man here's the thing for you you
might believe this it might be true for
you you might have even been through
some races experience or whatever I'm
not even gonna deny the fact or put it
brush it under the rug because it exists
racism does exist and it sucks right
everyone that's listening to this
whether you're Asian or not I want you
to realize that you have the power to
change at all in your own experience
Ariane's and like you know maybe through
these talks or maybe through these
podcasts you can find that confidence
within yourself because at the end of
the day I don't want people to feel like
attacked for their thoughts and beliefs
I just want you to realize that there is
an alternative to your world like you
don't have to be in that situation there
is a there's a certain group of Asian
guys that are out there that are pushing
this [ __ ] thought that are thinking
we're low value that other races don't
like us as much and they think they said
on your side that they're trying to
build you up and they're not there to me
that's perpetuating a thought in a
culture that I [ __ ] hate yeah they're
allowing you to wallow in your self-pity
and your hate and they're feeding off
that [ __ ] they are because it's
validating their own insecurities and
now that they found another group of
people who feel that way instead of
lifting each other up they're like no we
this is where we're at and we're gonna
be angry at the rest of the world and
I'm not even gonna there's certain okay
there's certain catchphrases like where
there's there's certain thoughts like Oh
a ver egde Asian guy versus an average
white guy you know the white guy's gonna
do better and dating like they believe
weird [ __ ] [ __ ] like I don't
understand what is that what is it where
did you get that exactly but first off
it's like how do you even what is even
average yeah what is the criteria
average it's so subjective it's based
off of this stupid low self-esteem
thinking and to me I I [ __ ] refuse it
and I refuse to believe it because
that's not my world and that's not the
world of a lot of people around me and I
think I want people out there to realize
that don't fall into this way of
thinking because it's so poisonous to
your mind and it's guaranteed failure
and it's guaranteed low self-esteem and
so there is a way out right and the
whole goal for us I think is we've
always been at the forefront of shaping
culture for people for our you know we
have a different way of thinking because
maybe we think more of a pioneer than
someone who's a who's a who's reacting
to what's happening yeah right for us
it's like okay I see there's a problem
not even gonna deny it but let me go my
own way and maybe I can pave something
so that
other people can can feel confident in
saying like oh these [ __ ] idiots do
it I can do it too
yeah right and to show that there's
other ways of thinking and there's way
better alternatives and for you if
you're if you're out there and you're
just like okay I used to think kind of
shitty about my own situation in my own
people and dating or whatever you can
now take matters into your own hands and
change your own luck and change your own
destiny and you can literally you you
every day that you're alive you are
writing your own story at the end of the
day when when whatever all your chapters
closed what is the story that you're
writing about yourself yeah right like
what is that how you want to end it is
is this is this where the the I don't
know [ __ ] whatever
I don't know Phillip Wong or something
like that lays and that's that's the one
food I never mind no that's he's
weighing okay thank God no right wait no
it's when it's Wang oh its wing that's
right so let's say Phillip Chang all
right let's say Phillip Chang like
you're is that the story that you want
to tell about yourself like out of all
the life experiences that you had things
that you could have done and you go you
know what at the end of the day my
chapter or my books gonna end at the
world hates me nobody finds me it's
right the way we're not talking about
Wang who we love those oh yeah yeah no
they're not he's by the way Phillip it's
[ __ ] engaged yeah he knows he knows
how to date and being in love so he's
good I mean he writes about it all the
time yeah so you know what I'm saying is
like if you out there mr. Phillip Ching
Chang Chang Ching when you're writing
this story and that's where that's the
narrative of your book is that I am
unattractive because of my race and this
is where I like yes this is it you have
an ability to change that narrative it's
there it's there for you I'm not saying
it's easy maybe if you live in a very in
area where Asian men aren't found
attractive yeah but you do have that
ability to do it or they might not find
themselves unattractive but they might
have this pre perception that others
find them unattractive so they're not
even gonna try approaching them or
making friends or making any type of
connection with these women yeah and the
comedy side of me wants to say if you're
a [ __ ] ugly loser that's probably the
reason why so you need to build on the
strengths if your ugly [ __ ] person
make em laugh make them laugh make make
your insides beautiful make become a
butterface work on your body or whatever
but at the end of the day dude it all
comes down to being able to connect with
another human being it really is yeah
like I think the biggest thing was like
Mariel and I connected on on a very
Lycus on say like spiritual just human
level yeah and that's what made me like
so attracted to her and that's what made
her attracted to me so and and women are
giving us the answer 24/7 like I guess
that a lot of guys are just not
listening and they always say
personality personality I like
personality right and then like a lot of
guys just can't believe how simple it is
and then also to you know clean
yourselves up a little bit but
definitely the person I think is a big
thing to do with it well guys that wraps
up this episode of the genius brain
podcast coming in with that [ __ ] heat
you guys already know every Thursday is
gonna have Joe unless he has bronchitis
or some [ __ ] again you know but every
Thursday we're gonna try to keep this
stuff very like topic focus I I I asked
a lot of people when I was doing a
couple of college tours like what they
like and they said that they like the
focused topics every now and then with
me and Joe so I love it too man it keeps
a nice precise so you guys can find us
every Thursday every Sunday genius brain
uploads take us on the commute have us
just I don't know change your lives get
that dead card and that [ __ ] wet I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm saying
being that give us that fire star leave
the comments below and we'll talk to you
and see you next time peace